tu as entre 15 et 18 ans tu vas au lycée
et comme la plupart des jeunes de ton
âge tu écoute du rap
jusque là rien d'anormal tu adolescents
tu as un âge où on a besoin de
s'identifier à des figures rebelles pour
pouvoir construire son identité donc
écouter des paroles vulgaires ou pseudo
révolutionnaires sur de la grosse
rythmique à ton âge c'est cohérent
seulement voilà le problème tu écoute du
rap et à côté de ça quand tu es en cours
de français tu t'emmerdes et tu trouves
ça sans intérêt
la littérature les figures de style
l'analyse de texte tout ça c'est pas mon
truc et c'est là qu'il ya quelque chose
qui ne va pas parce qu aimer le rap et
ne pas aimer le français c'est pas
compatible
tu ne peux pas aimer le rap et ne pas
intéresser aux français parce que le rap
c'est du français
le rap c'est du langage c'est le
maniement des mots s'est sculpté le
verbe pour faire naître des images et
des impressions
c'est le principe même de la poésie
jouer sur les possibilités qu'offre la
lampe pour véhiculer des idées vous
transmettre des émotions
donc quand tu écoute du rap tu écoutes
un texte qui a été précisément écrit
pour produire tel effet à tel moment tu
écoutes une oeuvre littéraire et pour te
convaincre je me suis dit que le mieux
c'était de te le prouver dans cette
vidéo je suis donc allé chercher cette
procédé littéraire dans les chansons
d'une référence en matière de rap booba
booba est sans doute l'un des rappeurs
français les plus adeptes des figures
littéraires
quoi qu'on pense du personnage le fait
est qu'on trouve dans ses textes toute
la panoplie des procédés littéraires
qu'on étudie en français au lycée
si après cette vidéo tu trouves toujours
que l'étude du français n'a aucun
intérêt quand on aime le rap alors je
suis désolé de le dire c'est que tu ne
connais rien au rap
donc voilà comment ça va se passer je
vais passer plusieurs extraits et on va
analyser ensemble les procédés qu'ils
contiennent j'ai près alors c'est parti
on les meneurs ont plein tube alors quel
est le procédé utilisé ici si tu ne vois
pas devant toi si tu as déjà vu des
paroles avec des menottes aux poignets
en effet les paroles n'ont pas de
poignée elles n'ont pas de poignée car
elles n'ont pas de corps car elles ne
sont pas des personnes la figure de
style utilisé ici c'est la
personnification c'est quand on décrit
une chose on lui attribuant des
caractéristiques humaines parler de
parole ayant les menottes ça peut
signifier que le message que transmet
booba fait l'objet d'une censure ou pro
l'empêchent de s'exprimer librement
ça peut aussi signifier que ses paroles
sont le reflet d'une violence qu'ils
expriment à travers l'exemple d'une
arrestation policière bien sûr personne
n'est dans la tête de booba pour
vérifier que c'est bien cette
signification là et pas une autre qu'il
a voulu donner à sa phrase mais un
procédé littéraire n'a pas besoin d'être
volontaire pour être techniquement
valable retiens ça suffit
pour elle
ça me convient
si on écoute se refera sans faire
attention on pourrait croire que nous
bat parle tout simplement de la femme
qu'il aime d'ailleurs le titre tombé
pour elle est une référence explicite à
la chanson de pascal obispo dans
laquelle le chanteur déclare son amour
pour une femme
[Musique]
je pourrais
mais en réalité quand on écoute la
première phrase du refrain on s'aperçoit
que booba ne fait pas référence à une
femme et à la rue
[Musique]
c'est la rue qui est ici pas se méfier
c'est donc l'amour de la rue qu'exprime
banon ce refrain en jouant sur
l'ambiguïté pour créer une image décalée
et surprenante
il ya une autre figure de style qui
permet de s'exprimer à partir d'image
c'est la métaphore
la métaphore est une comparaison son
outil de comparaison elle consiste à
remplacer selon qu'on parle par autre
chose afin de mettre en avant l'un de
ses aspects exemple de meta forte
en comparant le corps d'une femme à un
coffre fort goût bas souligne son
caractère précieux c'est une manière
d'exprimer l'intensité de son attirance
pour elle de plus en déclarant vouloir
s'emparer de ce coffre fort booba
insinue qu'il veut séduire cette femme à
la manière d'un cambrioleur ou d'un
braqueur de banques volé son coeur pour
en être l'unique propriétaire
tu trouves que ça va trop loin écoute
bien
[Musique]
je remarque que tu tu remarques booba
prolonge sa métaphore du coffre fort
dans les vers suivants en évoquant les
codes de sécurité et en parlant des
fractions qui désigne le fait de
pénétrer dans un lieu sans en avoir
l'autorisation on appelle ça une
métaphore filée c'est une métaphore qui
se poursuit sur plusieurs lignes
personnification comparaison métaphore
toutes ces figures de style on entrait
en commun elle fonctionne sur le
principe de l'analogie l'analogie ça
consiste à faire un parallèle avec une
situation sans rapport mais qui a un
rapport par exemple si je te dis que le
rap c'est de la boxe avec des rimes à la
place des points
tu comprends l'idée tu sais très bien
que le rap et la boxe ça n'a rien à voir
mais tu saisis la comparaison
c'est ça une analogie l'analogie est un
procédé très efficace pour produire des
images qui parlent à l'esprit on utilise
l'analogie pour décrire une situation
sans avoir besoin de passer par de
longues phrases d'explication elle peut
également créer un effet comique lorsque
les deux choses mises en relation
appartiennent à des univers totalement
différent
quelques exemples j'ai vu le portrait
qu'il n'appelle en herbe qui couronne
sur la tête pourtant elle
sa carrière tankers pas trop qu'on va se
crasher et forêts du voile avec 1
nicola ventola deux très grosses
secondes bac dans le rap il y a deux
sortes de figures de style qu'on
retrouve souvent en raison de leur
efficacité
les figures d'analogie on vient d'en
voir quelques unes et les figures
d'opposition parmi les figures
d'opposition la plus connue est
l'antithèse l'antithèse c'est lorsque
l'auteur établit une opposition entre
deux idées contraires les rappeurs ont
souvent recours à ce procédé pour
exprimer le fait qu'ils sont en révolte
contre le monde contre les règles les
institutions chez booba ça peut donner
ça par exemple les hommes et entre à
moment jeu comme un droit
j'ai couru comme un esclave pour marcher
comme l'antithèse peut aussi servir à
souligner un paradoxe à renforcer un
contraste ou à créer un décalage comique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'antithèse se marie très bien avec une
autre figure de style qu'on appelle le
parallélisme le parallélisme consiste à
juxtaposer de propositions ayant la même
structure grammaticale exemple c'est une
manière de renforcer l'antithèse en
créant une impression de répétition
c'est un procédé très utilisé dans la
publicité parce qu'il permet de créer
des formules slogan les phrases qui nous
reste dans la tête et qu'on n'arrive
plus à effacer
si vous by devenu une sorte de chef
d'orchestre de la punchline ce n'est pas
seulement en raison de son recours
fréquent aux figures de style c'est
aussi grâce à son sens du rythme et de
la musicalité des mots le rap de booba
est très axé sur les sonorités et la
prononciation
on entend les mots davantage qu'on les
comprend c'est une caractéristique de la
poésie
le texte n'est pas simplement fait pour
être lu il est aussi fait pour être
entendu le maniement des sons fait donc
partie intégrante des procédés politique
et parmi les procédés politique
il y en a un que tous les chanteurs ont
l'obligation de connaître cela-dit erez
lavier rays c'est le fait de prononcer
10 et reiz au lieu de prononcer dirais
c'est une manière dé tirer le mot pour
gagner une syllabe dans le vert et
respecter ainsi la réplique est chez
nous ballade i rèss c'est récurrent
comprend que robin tu finis thérapie
je suis dans le deuil quand même s'ils
préféraient pas sa vie volée
j'ai pris l'eau dce anti écouter sentir
aux très jeunes africains comme à nancy
dans chacun de ces extraits on a
l'impression que toutes les raisons
étaient voulues par booba comme si le
non plus on avait juste servi de
prétexte pour étirer les autres le jeu
sur les sonorités on le retrouve aussi
dans ce qu'on appelle la parano maze la
paronomase c'est le fait d'utiliser des
mots proches au niveau sonore pour créer
une impression de fluidité ou de
répétition
là encore l'idée qu'on peut transmettre
plus de choses par le son des mots que
par leur sens par exemple je peux pas
rivaliser
on va te des balises et de déraciner
tout est calciné devant parce que l'on
perd ce mauvais réseau faire imprimer en
rimes sur l'oreille au bulldozer
portuaire et la rivale de paysages
mortuaire en banlieue mais norme est
sûre on veut dans la came sport un autre
procédé qui consiste à jouer sur le son
des mots c'est l'allitération la
libération c'est la répétition d'un même
son console comme dans ce célèbre vers
de racine pour qui sont ces serpents qui
sifflent sur vos têtes
leçon s est répétée pour suggérer
phonétiquement le sifflement du serpent
chez booba ça pourra donner
[Musique]
roulement plus
sans qu'on s'en aperçoive booba a inséré
une allitération dans ces deux vers le
son de la lettre v se répète comme pour
mieux suggérer l'idée du vent qui
porterait la plus le son vient ici
renforcer l'idée exprimée dans les
paroles encore une fois la question
n'est pas de savoir si google utilise
ces procédés volontairement ou
inconsciemment
la question est de savoir si ces
procédés sont bel et bien présents dans
ses textes
et la réponse est oui quelle que soit
notre opinion sur le rap force est de
constater qu'il s'agit d'une des
dernières passerelle entre la jeunesse
et l'univers des lettres et même si je
ne dois pas forcément d'un bon oeil le
fait qu'on étudie les chansons de diam's
au lycée je pense malgré tout que ça
peut constituer un levier imparfait mais
nécessaire à la reconnexion des jeunes
avec la culture ça n'a aucun sens de
vouloir comparer booba à paul-valéry
baudelaire ou rimbaud
ça n'a aucun intérêt de se demander si
les rappeurs sur les nouveaux poètes
l'important c'est de comprendre qu'on
n'a pas besoin d'être écrivain poète ou
chanteurs pour jouer avec les subtilités
de la langue française
et que plus tu maîtrisera talons de plus
tu sauras exprimé de choses
c'est ça l'intérêt du français à prendre
à dire et apprendre à entendre
[Musique]
merci d'avoir suivi cet épisode
abonnez-vous et partager la vidéo ça
vous a plu
n'oubliez pas de vous abonner à la page
facebook le précepteur et un grand merci
à tous ceux qui me soutiennent sur tipi
vous me donner du courage et de la
motivation je vous dis à bientôt pour un
prochain épisode
on lit où on écrit de la poésie non pas
parce que c'est joli
on lit et on écrit de la poésie parce
que l'on fait partie de l'humanité et
que l'humanité est faite de passion
[Musique]
et